you know macron is on a three-day State
visit to Beijing where he's holding
talks with Chinese Premier Lee Chung
macron will meet president Xi Jinping
later on Thursday Lena Abu aklay has
more
this is Emmanuel macron's first visit to
China in four years with the aim he says
of engaging Beijing toward a shared
responsibility for peace and stability
China says it's seeking to play a
mediating role between Russia and
Ukraine
some Western Powers fear Beijing May
instead be preparing to send arms to
Moscow
but the French President says he doesn't
believe China wants a lasting war in
Europe
China has proposed a peace plan and we
have welcomed it but do we agree with it
in its entirety no but it is interesting
and it shows willingness to commit to
resolving the conflict I hope to be able
to participate in initiatives that are
useful to the Ukrainian population
volunteer
macron and she will also discuss
development of bilateral relations and
boosting economic ties in that too
president macron is charting a different
course in Washington the talk is
increasingly about decoupling from
China's economy
and the European commission president
Ursula vanderlein set to join macron in
Beijing spoke last week about de-risking
Europe's business connections with China
while still calling for sustained
relations
the trip has been welcomed by China's
business community
I think this visit can further promotion
strengthen trade between the two
countries in the era of globalization
and interdependence European leaders are
not in favor of decoupling ties and want
to continue strengthening cooperation
with China
at a time when the U.S is taking its
toughest stance on Beijing every Nuance
of these talks will be watched closely
Al Jazeera
well let's bring in Brian Wong he is a
Rhodes scholar and geopolitical advisor
he joins us from Hong Kong thank you
very much for being on Al Jazeera first
of all how delicate a balance is this
for macron pushing for stronger economic
ties while at the same time trying to
warn China not to side with Russia when
it comes to the war in Ukraine how does
he manage that balance
thank you very much for having me and I
would say that actually macron Is
straddling two sets of delicate balances
the first set is as you noted the
economic attempts at establishing
deepening ties and also resuming trade
relations in the aftermath of covid
that's certainly an objective that
macron has on a table and yet the extent
to which that would inevitably be
colored by or diluted by the broader
geopolitical friction remains to be seen
and one could only remain hope for and
optimistic that nebuchron would be able
to navigate some sort of tendentious
balance in rhetoric and also
substantively pushing forward I guess
better policies on the ground despite
remaining rhetorically committed to I
suppose a more cautious recalibration in
European policy towards China and the
second straddle that he must also
consider is French national interests
versus the broader interests of Europe
as he flagged he's coming on a trip
alongside the commission president
Ursula Von delayin and this is a signal
that France does not want to be you know
separated or decoupled from if anything
would like to play a leading role in
steering Brussels policy towards China
so there's a clear affirmation of the
European identity there and yet how
macron can balance that against a
growing and Rising tides of sinus
skepticism amongst many of the members
in Europe in the European Union that's
again a delicate balance that he must
navigate with care and Prudence do you
think he'll be able to do all of that in
a three-day trip
I don't think you'd be able to do all of
that but I certainly think you can make
some promising progress and Headway in
two distinctive ways the first is what
does that look like assuring sorry to
interrupt what is it what is it what
would that look like at the end of this
trip
I think that looks like essentially
firstly an affirmation that China would
remain fundamentally committed to not
supplying lethal Aid in Military Arms
and equipment to Russia but also an
attempt to broker a sort of medium to
long term cease-fire and peace talk
schedule and that comes in the form of
effectively outlining expectations as to
where and when and with what agenda
items in mind these peace talks are due
to be carried out and conducted in the
medium to long-term Horizon but I don't
see you know any immediate breakthroughs
as likely simply cause geopolitical
environments at large don't favorites
some American relations remain fraught
and there's clearly deepening trust and
also strategic interdependence when it
comes to China Russia and other members
of the brics Nations and Central Asia at
large so I do not see you know sort of
this this day taunt and breakthrough is
likely yeah we saw uh president XI meet
with Vladimir Putin not that long ago
and put forward the China's peace plan
uh to try and end the war in Ukraine
what sort of role I mean how realistic
do you think it is that China will play
a significant part in negotiating any
future peace
so I think two things essentially on
that the first is that China is
definitely keen on establishing you know
a clearer presence and more vocal
presence in neutrality and passivism on
Surface and a peace plan affirms you
know effectively it's ployed to play to
the global South and also its
affirmation of not being interventionist
and not taking sides and yet in practice
the real question and challenge for
China is firstly will it be able to
convince Ukraine it is a good faith
actor that is willing to indeed
negotiate and mediate in an even-handed
Manner and secondly will the European
Union especially the countries that are
currently wavering and more critical of
China's role and presence be willing to
come on board that very process of
mediation and talk it out with Ukraine
we're not the White House reciprocates
is again the third determinative factor
and that's also a factor that China has
to bear in mind and caution against as
it seek to set guard rails inside
American relations one of the core
objectives of that too is to get America
at a very least not object and to
actively oppose its efforts and attempt
into broker a China favorable or more
broadly speaking Global South favorable
peace package over Ukraine and that to
me is a vital question there okay we'll
have to leave it there thank you so much
for your time and you're inside that is
Brian Wong a geopolitical advisor in
Hong Kong thank you
thank you very much